Turkey's president reg API a Bedouin is
using a failed military coup to tighten
his grip on power more than 250 people
died in a night of street battles and
aerial bombardments on the 15th of July
2016
but for Turks revolt is nothing new the
country experienced coos in 1960 1971
1980 and in 1997 the Prime Minister
stepped down under pressure from the
military Iran has been encouraged by the
botched uprising widening a purge of
more than 80,000 soldiers judges
academics and other officials the latest
highlights one of turkey's biggest
problems a division that's tearing the
country apart so here's the situation
Turkey's political identity echoes its
geography straddling the Middle East in
Europe it's a nation where East meets
West the father of modern Turkey is the
military officer Mustafa Kemal atatürk
who led the nation at the founding of
the post Ottoman state in 1923
since then the Turkish Armed Forces have
played a central role in maintaining the
secular Western looking society Ataturk
envisioned the a.k party was first
elected in 2002 with a Hawaiian becoming
Prime Minister the following year as
turkey's most powerful ruler since
Ataturk erawan is instead molding Turkey
back into an Islamic world power by
giving a voice to an underclass of
Islamic conservatives many Turks loved
him the size of the economy nearly
tripled in a decade but over the last
few years he stifled political debate
while fighting accusations of corruption
in 2014 he began purging the police and
judiciary detained journalists and
tightened control of the Internet he
says those responsible for the latest
coup attempt are followers of Fethullah
Gulen and Islamic cleric in self-imposed
exile in the u.s. that's been denied by
Gulen who was once an ally but then
became a critic of a Dolan's government
accusing it of corruption an early one
has not been shy about his ambitions
building a 1150 room presidential palace
a complex four times the size of
Versailles and over 30 times larger than
the White House
here's the argument while they're too
earnest announced for being increasingly
autocratic he still admired his party's
rule has been the longest period of
political stability since the Second
World War
he's built hospitals and schools poorer
Turks have seen living standards rise
under his control
over the years the Turkish people have
been divided on what they think about
the man in charge
Turkey's been a member of NATO since
1952 but it hasn't been able to join the
EU which has been critical of the
country's track record on civil
liberties and lack of democratic reform
loved and loathed by many
Oh Doan doesn't look like he has plans
to leave power anytime soon